THIS IS CNN NEWSROOM WITH
ROSEMARY CHURCH.
>> AND THANKS FOR JOINING, US
THE DEATH TOLL HAS RISEN AND
THE VOLCANIC DISASTER IN TONGA.
AT LEAST 2 PEOPLE IN THE ISLAND
COUNTRY HAVE BEEN KILLED
FOLLOWING SATURDAY'S ENORMOUS
ERUPTION.
AND THE TSUNAMI THAT FOLLOWED.
AS MUCH WE STILL DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE FULL IMPACT OF THE --
CUT OFF FROM MUCH OF THE WORLD.
NOW THIS WAS THE SCENE ON
FRIDAY AFTER THE FIRST ERUPTION
BEFORE SATURDAY'S MORE POWERFUL
BLAST.
THE AGENCY SAYING CHILDREN
SAYING THE TSUNAMI DESTROYED AT
LEAST 50 HOMES AND TONGA AND
DAMAGED MORE THAN 100 OTHERS.
RELIEF GROUPS SAY AT THE TOP
PRIORITY IS GETTING CLEAN WATER
AND FOOD TO THE PEOPLE OF TONGA,
OVER FEARS THE VOLCANIC ASH MAY
LIKELY CONTAMINATE SUPPLIES
THERE.
OIL NAVY SHIPS FROM NEW ZEALAND
ARE EXPECTED TO DEPLOY IN THE
COMING HOURS WITH MUCH NEEDED
HUMANITARIAN AID.
UNDERWATER COMMUNICATION LINES
REMAIN SEVERELY DISRUPTED, AND
ASH CLOUDS HAVE MADE IT
DIFFICULT TO FULLY ASSESS THE
IMPACT OF THE DISASTER.
CNN METEOROLOGIST TYLER MORGAN
JOINS ME NOW LIVE, AND ATLANTA.
BUT LET'S START WITH OUR BLAKE
WHO IS LIVE IN TOKYO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
SO, BLAKE, WHY ARE WE LEARNING
ABOUT THE SITUATION AND TONGA,
AND WHEN AID MIGHT ARRIVE THERE?
>> YOU KNOW, ROSEMARY, WE KNOW
THAT FALLING ASH REMAINS A HUGE
PROBLEM.
IT IS BECAUSE OF THAT ASH THAT
OUTSIDE AID HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO
ARRIVE.
ACCORDING TO AUSTRALIA'S
MINISTER OF DEFENSE, PLANES
CARRYING AID CAN'T LAND BECAUSE
ASHES RENDERED THE RUNWAY
UNUSABLE.
TO ILLUSTRATE THAT POINT, CHECK
OUT THESE BEFORE AND AFTER
PICTURES LOOKING DOWN ON
TONGA'S MAIN ISLAND.
EVERYTHING IS SEEMINGLY COVERED
IN ASH.
AS A RESULT, NEW ZEALAND HAS
SAID TO OIL NAVY SHIPS WILL
ASSIST WITH THE RECOVERY, BUT
IT WILL LIKELY TAKE THEM ABOUT
3 DAYS BEFORE THEY ARRIVE.
NOW FOR THOSE NOT FAMILIAR WITH
TONGA, IT IS MADE UP OF MORE
THAN 170 ISLANDS AND HOME TO
ABOUT HUNDRED 70,000 PEOPLE.
THIS REMOTE ISLAND CHAIN IS
LOCATED IN THE SOUTH PACIFIC
ABOUT 800 KILOMETERS EAST OF
FIJI, AND 2400 KILOMETERS AWAY
FROM NEW ZEALAND.
SO, AT THIS POINT, SO FAR, ONLY
SURVEILLANCE FLIGHTS HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO BE CARRIED OUT.
ACCORDING TO NEW ZEALAND'S
GOVERNMENT SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE
CAN BE SEEN ALONG THE WESTERN
COAST OF TONGA'S MAIN ISLAND.
NEW ZEALAND'S HIGH COMMISSIONER
AND HUNGER ALSO SAYS VOLCANIC
ERUPTION DAMAGE COMMUNICATION
CAPABILITIES.
SO FOR THE TIME BEING, WITH
COMMUNICATION EXTREMELY LIMITED,
THE ISLAND NATION IS
ESSENTIALLY CUT OFF FROM THE
REST OF THE WORLD AS YOU SAID.
LEAVING FRIENDS AND FAMILY
TRYING TO CHECK ON LOVED ONES
WITH LITTLE TO NO RESPONSE,
THAT INCLUDES AID WORKERS.
EARLIER TODAY CNN SPOKE WITH
KATIE GREENWOOD WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL RED CROSS WHO
SAYS SHE WAS ABLE TO BRIEFLY
MAKE CONTACT WITH HER
COLLEAGUES IN CONGO TOLD HER
THINGS ARE GOING RELATIVELY
WELL.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE ARE VERY FOCUSED ON THE
WATER EMERGENCY THAT MAY BE
EMERGING AS A RESULT OF THE ASH
FALL INTO THE MAIN WATER
SOURCES.
THAT WILL BE A FOCUS OF OUR
EFFORT IN THE COMING DAYS.
BUT WE ARE ALSO FOCUSED ON
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
THE NECESSARY ITEMS THEY
REQUIRE TO SHORE UP AND REMEDY
THEIR HOUSES THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY ASH FALL AND
INUNDATION FROM THE TSUNAMI
WAVES AS WELL.
>> WHILE GREENWOOD SAYS THINGS
SEEM STABLE ON THE MAIN ISLAND,
SHE SAYS THERE IS A BIG CONCERN
FOR SOME OF THE LOW LYING AREAS
AND ISLANDS CLOSER TO THE
ERUPTION SITE.
--
METER TALL TSUNAMI WAVE WHICH
DAMAGED ABOUT 100 HOMES, FOR
NOW THE BIG CONCERN IS THE ASH
FALL.
SAVE THE CHILDREN SAYS DRINKING
WATER SUPPLIES COULD BE
CONTAMINATED AND THERE IS THE
IMMEDIATE CONCERN FOR TONGA'S
AIR AND WATER SAFETY.
ROSEMARY?
>> ALL RIGHT, MANY THANKS TO
YOU, BLAKE, APPRECIATE.
THAT TYLER, WANT TO GO TO YOU
NOW.
WHAT MORE ARE YOU SEEING IN
TERMS OF CONDITIONS ON THE
GROUND IN THE REGION?
>> YES, ROSEMARY, OF COURSE WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE AT
LEAST SOME SMALL ISSUES WITH
THE TONGA ERUPTION.
THE INITIAL ERUPTION ON
SATURDAY WAS JUST SO HUGE, THIS
IS AN ERUPTION THAT WOULD ONLY
OCCUR ONCE EVERY 1000 YEARS.
LAST TIME IT ERUPTED WAS BACK
IN 2014, 2015.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS YET
ANOTHER VOLCANIC ERUPTION
WITHIN THE RING OF FIRE WHICH
IS WHERE 90% OF THE WORLD'S
EARTHQUAKES ACTUALLY OCCUR.
AS A RESULT, YOU ALSO GET THE
SEISMIC ACTIVITY AND VOLCANOES
HERE.
SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO SEE SOME
SMALL ISSUES THERE, MAYBE MORE
IN THE WAY OF SEISMIC ACTIVITY
AND WHATNOT.
YOU CAN SEE HERE TO THE ASH
CLOUD THAT WENT SO HIGH UP INTO
THE AIR, ABOUT 45, 50, MAYBE
60,000 FEET INTO THE AIR AND
SPREAD ALL OF THIS OVER
AUSTRALIA AND ELSEWHERE.
LEADING TO THE ISSUES WHICH WE
JUST MENTIONED A 2ND AGO, AND A
SHOCKWAVE CREATED A TSUNAMI
WHICH DID CAUSE DAMAGE AS WE
HAVE SEEN.
NOTICE THE ASH COVERING THE
GROUND HERE, THIS IS JUST
PHENOMENAL STAFF FROM HUGE A
HUGE EXPLOSION AND HISTORIC
EXPLOSION.
NOTICE THE BEFORE AND AFTER
RIGHT HERE OF THE ISLAND.
YOU CAN SEE IT IS RIGHT THERE
ON DECEMBER 8TH, BUT